[Music]
what we're gonna do is i'm going to
blunder a piece on move five or six of
this next game i've done it a couple of
times before but i did it about 400
rating points ago and i barely won
so this is going to be a huge challenge
i'm likely to lose this game i'm gonna
put that out there right now i'm likely
to lose this game but i'm going to try
to give you guys a window into how i
obviously how i try to create chances
and lost positions and we'll use that to
discuss
with you know proper conversion
technique as well as proper defensive
techniques so we're gonna try here we go
bprs2000 and i'm going to try to make it
look like it's a mouse slip or something
but often what happens is that people
refuse to take the piece people are too
nice
okay so i'm just going to play four
nights
i don't know yeah i saw hershey nakamura
but i'm not sure if it's ikaro
all right so here's what we're going to
do we're going to give up our knight
but not yet not yet
okay i'm going to play knight take c5
now at least i'm going to get a pawn for
it i hope it's fair like at least i'm
going to get a pawn for the piece um
which is a little bit something but it's
completely lost okay so we're on night
down
okay now obviously we have not completed
our development so for now there is not
much that we can do other
than to
complete our development we need to
castle we need to play d3
uh in no particular order i mean let's
let's
start by playing d3
then we should castle and then we need
to start thinking in earnest okay queen
f6 so black is trying to checkmate us i
already think this is an encouraging
sign i don't like queen f6 i think that
walks right into our hands
we castle obviously right we have castle
we need to defend f2
and the drawback of the move queen f6 is
of course that it walks into
a potential knight d5 right but that's
what black is trying to prevent knight
g7 so this is a viable setup from our
opponent
and now i'm going to make an interesting
move
um
when you're down a piece like this
there are different ways of trying to
defend right there's defensive moves if
you can find a move that
that improves your position but also
sets a trap those are the best kind of
moves right moves that
you know set a trap of some sort but
also improve your position so one such
idea would be to play bishop c1 to e3
because if black would automatically
trade then we would take back with the f
pawn and notice that we would be
actually attacking f7 from two different
sources so bishop e3 is a
logical move but
i think i see a more
uh serious idea because after bishop b3
our opponent is going to see that and
he's going to play bishop b6 and we're
going to regret playing it curious
chimpanzee mentioned a very important
thing we want to be able to play a 4. if
we can get a 4 in if we can open up the
f file hey we'll start getting some
chances so king h1 right this is a
classic idea
castles and bang f4 we're starting to
open the file
and already we've made a little bit of
progress we've created
a little bit of intrigue on the king's
side
okay what should we take with who can
tell me
we should absolutely take with the
bishop taking with the rook would guild
the instant gratification of attacking
the queen
but i love that i think almost all of
you guys see that just because the move
attacks the queen doesn't mean it's a
good move and the rook on f4 would be
terribly misplaced queen g6
okay well
we also need to realize that we're only
a piece down so if we can get three
pawns for the piece
you know material is already gonna be
equal so
hey
three pawns they don't lie by the side
of the road we're taking that
we're taking that pawn bishop g4
okay well we need to move our queen
where should we move it well we have
several squares we can play queen up to
d2
another interesting idea is to play
queen e1 and try to drag the queen over
to the king side
but the reason i don't like queen e1 as
much is because it walks into knight c6
to d4 and we want to make sure that our
c2 pawn
is protected so for that reason
i want to bring the queen up to d2 and
we can also move it up to f4 later so
it's not like we are yeah there we go so
black blaze knight d4
this no longer carries a thread and it
gives us an extra tempo
what should we do with this tempo okay
now let me think for a second so here's
my idea we have many many moves here
right we have many moves here
i am going to play the cryptic looking
bishop c7 to e5
now the point of this move and i'm not
saying that this is such a genius move
or anything of the sort
we are putting pressure on the knight on
d4 i am hoping i am sincerely hoping
that black plays the move knight e7 to
c6 if i have a good understanding of how
players at this level think
we might be successful no we're not
queen h5 okay
i mean
this is just a different way of
attacking e5 which is even better
i will explain after the game what i had
in mind
now we have to drop the bishop back to
g3 which is something i was going to do
anyway i was going to play bishop c7 to
g3 anyway just to get this bishop away
from c7 that's a super awkward square
that bishop could get caught in a bunch
of different tactical ideas so i think
it makes a lot of sense to bring it back
to home base
sadly that trick did not work oh but it
kind of did because black made a move
that has the same effect as knight e to
c6
why is it
that i wanted black to move the knight
away from e7 what does that allow us now
to do
what does that now allow us to do
think about it well what squares was the
knight protecting well it was protecting
the d5 square we can play now the move
knight d5 we can start accumulating
pressure in the center what is our next
move likely to be well our next move is
likely to now be c3
oh
that's a nasty move though
that's a really nasty move i would be
lying if i said i saw that move but we
can deal with it
now i actually need to think
that's a move that just totally escaped
my attention to be honest
yeah this is bad
this is really really really really bad
because
bishop f2 would be defending but there's
bishop d6
bishop f2 bishop d6 queenie one is
possible so queenie one is our emergency
move
yeah queenie one is our emergency move
but we can also bring bishop back to c7
but then black plays rook aca
and then we really don't have any moves
at all
ah then maybe we can play d4 but the
knight takes d4
yeah unfortunately
uh
we have to play queen e1 okay that's
forced
yeah black is playing very well here i
mean 92 just totally totally escaped me
i forgot about that square
hopefully everybody was able to see why
it was such a problem
because like knight takes g3 is
literally a maid threat okay he takes it
now taking actually helps us a little
bit because now i feel like black has
has
has
greatly reduced his own attacking
chances
and on the next move we will be able to
play h3
and chase this bishop away from g4 and
at least our king is going to be a
little bit safer now let's not forget
that we have two pawns for the p so if
we can consolidate right if we can
remove the attack we will have serious
chances now
rookie d8 has created a threat the
threat is bishop to d6 skewering the
queen and if the queen moves we get
mated so it's very important to play h3
right now
without delay
taking the sting out of bishop d6 if
black plays bishop d6 here then we can
actually just take the bishop on g4
i'm anticipating bishop back to e6
and then we need to continue trying to
expand in the center our only advantage
here lies in our central pawn mass
which black does not have and so far our
opponent is playing super well like
there's very little that we can do with
black plays perfectly well we're hoping
that eventually he starts giving us a
little bit of breathing room
what should we do well
there isn't much we can do i think we
should play the move c3
in order to try to expand at the center
with d3 d4 and then maybe e4 e5 there
should be another great move
yeah i mean we're getting crushed here
uh the problem is just that queen e5 is
going to come next
and that's going to be
a big big big problem
okay so we have to go
okay i have an idea i have an idea
i mean this shouldn't work but the idea
that i have
is queen f2 i'm hoping the black sax on
h3
i'm hoping the black sax on h3
which is
would be a very bad idea i think well
maybe okay and maybe not such a bad idea
we take on h3 and i wasn't able to see
exactly where the mate is here
oh there's knight h4
wow this guy is amazing knight h4
threatens knight f3 check
queen takes f3 queen h to mate
oh but we might still have a defensive
move after knight h4 that might still
not be over i think that black didn't
see anything here but now he finds it
okay we have a defense here this is not
over yet
we are hanging by a thread
okay so what we need to do here
is we need to make a move that prevents
knight f3 why is knight f3 good well
it's because it distracts the queen from
f2
so what we need to do is we need to move
this queen to the side
and isn't it great that we played the
move c3 because now bishop c5 allows us
to meet allows d4
it's actually crucial that we have a
pawn on c3
so the point now is that if knight f3
happens we can take it with the rook and
h2 is still under our control now black
is a perpet if black wants to take a
draw here i am more than happy with that
by all means
if there was any way for black to lift
his rook to like h6 right now we would
be busted immediately but there isn't
i we might
might be holding on here i'll tell you
what worries me though what worries me
is a slow move like rookie eight
that's a really advanced move i mean
that's a move that
you know a lot of 2000s would have a
hard time playing because it's really
really slow and i don't see a defense
against the rook lift to e6
and i'd have to really hunker down and
find something there
draw would be amazing
but
i'm worried that given the way the game
is gone our opponent has been playing
super super well
okay in the meantime i'm trying to find
something against rookie a
okay bishop e5 this should be oh
that might be even better
intending this rook lifts are you
kidding me
holy smokes this guy
i have an idea though
not all has been lost i think we have a
well here's what i'm going to do
i am going to give him a check on e7
and then i'm going to drag
okay he's thinking
okay hello and then i'm going to drag
the knight back to f5 i'm trying
everything here
now the point of this move is to prevent
rook d6
and if knight takes f5 we can actually
take that knight and then we will have
the possibility of playing queen g2
and finally smoking that queen out of
there we are pretty close here to
holding this position together it's
still lost unfortunately if black plays
this carefully he should still be able
to grind us down on the king's side
he should still be able to grind us down
knight g6 no but that's
that's a mistake now that gives us a
chance here
i think we can start consolidating now
so for example but let's not let's not
celebrate because this guy is like
super good
okay so we need to get this queen out of
h3 we need to do it very very very
carefully
how should we do it
well we can play rook f3
or we can play queen g2 i think either
one of those moves is decent
i like rook f3 more though i like rook
f3 more
and i'll i'll explain to you guys why
after the game we're quite low on time
so i have to preserve some time on the
clock check
now we block with the queen queen g2 and
we've basically forced the queen trait
and through the lens of that queen trade
you can basically see why i played rook
f3 first what move are we taking the
sting out of
by playing rook f3 who can tell me after
the queen trade what move is no longer
that scary
no this guy played well he found a lot
of good moves i'm i never
implied that he's doing anything knight
f4 yeah exactly knight f4 is no longer
scary why isn't it scary well why was it
scary in the first place it was scary
because the pawn on d3 would have been
lost without our rook being on f3 does
that make sense so if the rook was now
on f1 knight f4 check the king would
have to move and now knight f4 is no
longer scary at all we can just move our
king to the side
where should we move it well i i want us
to have the potential to get this rook
into the game via h1 so
i feel that the best square for the king
is actually f2
in order to keep the first rank
unobstructed for the rookie goes g5
now we had a plan a while ago many moons
ago
that plan has gone nowhere it's still
our plan
what plan am i talking about
now the plan is to play d4 and expand in
the center but before we do that ladies
and gentlemen before we do that i think
it is very very important to prevent the
progress of this pawn actually wait
no no no we have a trap
oh wait we actually have
no let's go d4 i apologize
what i was worried about is the prospect
of black going g4
in this position
but upon closer investigation i realized
that we had to move bishop c7 i might
have to
uh you know shush a little bit and play
faster
but we still have time
now g4 is quite annoying
so
let us prevent that move by by shifting
the rook over to g3 to prevent g4 am i
not worried about a potential discovery
well black has no discovery black can
move the knight back sure but what's
going to be the effect of that
now one of our pieces is still not in
the game and that's the rook let's bring
it into the game via h1 we're also
creating a hidden potential beautiful
tactical idea
but it doesn't work just yet
h5 great move by our opponent
okay do you guys want to see something
crazy oh
i think i see something super cool
oh my god i think i see a beautiful idea
but it doesn't quite work we're gonna
try it though rook g4
okay wait wait oh we had a sack but it
didn't work we had a sack on h5 it
didn't work though i think black has an
only defensive move here if black does
not find this move he will get
checkmated let's see if he finds it if
he finds it
we just keep playing it's not the end of
the game
yeah rook d7 is the only move what is
the purpose of rook g4 we are preparing
a sacrifice on a4 there is a mating net
on the king
every square is protected and if we take
on h5 it's made he finds it oh this guy
he's good
okay um
we gotta reorient i actually think a
sack on f4 is still interesting
but we shouldn't do it okay guys let me
think for a second here how should we
play this i think the movie e5 is really
interesting here but it probably is not
going to work
knight g3 has rook h7 everything there's
a move everywhere
let's drop our rook back to g1
we got to get our rook back our rook on
g4 has now become a liability
okay now i'm going to have to focus i
don't want to lose this game i mean i'm
hoping for something like rookie 8 i'm
hoping for a blunder
our next move is likely
h7 good move
okay let's go bishop back to e2
i'm going to try to harass this pawn on
each oh
that gives us a square that gives us a
nice juicy square for the bishop look at
how we control the light squares we're
going to bring this king up to f3
oh and i blundered the pawn
yeah this guy is is out playing me it's
completely
but wait a second knight p2 rugby one
still still a game
knight c4 check king d3
no it's unclear i mean we have ooh
i didn't see that check either
i guess oh now he goes knight c4 and
knight back to d6 this is like
exquisite play by black
it's still it's still an absolute game
king d3 we're going to bring our king up
and now knight back to d6
knight a5 mistake mistake by our
opponent
okay what should we do now let's get our
rook to b5 let's activate our pieces
if b6
we're gonna shift this rook over to the
center rook d5 now white is much worse
no question about it but it's
it i mean black is a very hard time
pushing these king side pawns that's
what's hurting his chances the fact that
these two minor pieces are guarding
against the possibility of h3 oh he
disconnected
oh and he disconnected oh my god that's
really really sad because this guy has
just played an incredible game despite
giving the piece back up he was that
close to checkmating me
yeah
this is not good 30 seconds away from
auto resigning no but but he's gonna get
flagged anyway but still that was such a
high quality game
and there's so much to analyze this is
gonna be fun you guys stick around
for the analysis there's gonna be a lot
to talk about a lot of instructive ideas
that's an anticlimactic end to the game
and we definitely want to check with the
engine because there were some moments
that
i'm certainly not sure about
okay so let's jump into the analysis now
i'm not claiming that i played perfectly
here i think i played well enough to
hold him down so let's analyze now we
decided
to give up the piece knight takes e5 now
this is correct dtxt5 is is correct
uh knight takes c5 would be would be
worse because it would give us
more more of the center so so d e is is
sensible we play d3 and already early on
i i don't like i think black played the
next part of the game quite poorly and
then once we won the pawn on c7 black
started playing really really well again
queen f6 is unnecessary just go knight
f6 right just develop normally
right i feel like queen f6 gives us a
little bit of life because it
sets up knight d5 and it sets up f4
and uh
you know this this could be another so
after knight g7 at first i wanted to
play here and this sets a pretty nice
trap a lot of people especially at a
beginner level would automatically take
on e3
but when the pawn recaptures the f
f-file opens up the queen has to move
and we take on f7 and at this point it's
you know it's anybody's game
right
the problem with bishop e3 is that black
can drop the bishop back to b6 and we
haven't achieved anything from this
situation over here once black castles
king side then black can already take on
e3 if he wants
so instead
we
were able to come up with this idea of
pushing the pawn to f4 and we do that by
dragging the king to h1
castle short is correct
black can try to prevent f4 with knight
g6 but that in turn allows knight d5
can't you play knight a4 after bishop b6
asks it's dark rye so it's darker i
asked after bishop e3 bishop b6 what
about knight a4 well knight a4 is
possible
but uh black can still castle right and
you could claim yeah knight takes b6 a b
and f4 this would be an interesting way
of playing yeah yeah possible possible
but here black is already castled so at
this point opening up the f file is not
quite as effective
okay
so king h1
castles f4 opening up the file this
might be another inaccuracy i'm not sure
at this point already what black should
do because if black does not take on f4
well what does black do then right
because we actually could push this pawn
up to f5 and x communicate this bishop
and if we drive that pawn down to f5
that creates an attacking potential for
us on the king's side
so e takes f4 makes sense
yeah he's castled here too but at least
we our knight is still intact so our
knight has access to this potential d5
square
okay ng6 guys please do not imply that
he was cheating he was clearly not
cheating he was just playing a good game
as i always say without
any evidence accusing people is very
very bad practice
because always i i always say the same
thing every single time
you have a you know a twitchy trigger
finger on the cheating imagine if you
were this guy and you had just played a
really good game i'm sure you've played
a good game before with a high accuracy
just think about 2 000 people
reaching the opinion that you cheated
without even looking at the engine evils
how would you feel if if you know if
some if the community did that to you
um not very good i'm not that as you
guys know i am i call a spade a spade
and i'm suspicious of someone i say it
but you can't say it without
investigating first okay
so bishop takes c7 here's the second
pawn this is where the game started
turning i to be honest already felt that
we were gonna win this game pretty
straightforwardly because we already
have two pawns for the piece and we have
the center but black starts playing
super well here bishop g4 i'll check the
engine
queen d2
knight down to d4 great move this is a
good move this centralizes the knight
now i struggled figuring out what to do
in this position i think i made a
mistake here i think bishop e5 is a
mistake i played for tricks and this was
wrong i'm not sure what i should have
done here we will check the engine in
this position
we will check the engine in this
position to see how the computer would
propose that we defend this position
um but every move that i saw here was
bad in some way it's like weirdly we're
weirdly paralyzed yeah rook four was
proposed by some of you guys but i
didn't like what this did to our bishop
i felt like this leaves the bishop on c7
really vulnerable so for example black
could make the move even knight d4 to e6
here
and that forces us to give away our
incredibly valuable light-skirt bishop
of all the pieces i didn't want to give
away i didn't want to give away this
bishop and uh
but maybe this is not so bad because if
black plays f takes e6 we could actually
go after the light square bishop we
could actually go after that bishop and
go g4 so
maybe
rook f4 is interesting yeah the simple
h3 is possible but i thought that here
black could still go queen h5 and pin
the pawn
or or or drop the bishop back t6 so
something like that we should have done
instead i played the move bishop e5
i will put the engine on after we finish
analyzing without the engine
my idea was to induce this move and then
i thought we would drop the bishop back
to g3 and the point is that we would now
have the d5 square for our knight and we
would follow up by starting to push the
center pawns c3 and d4
unfortunately i overlooked this move
after bishop g3 i got excited again when
he played knight g6 i thought hey thank
you for the square we now have this
beautiful square for knight to be hon i
just i didn't even see the square like
the e2 square totally fell out of my
field of vision
and once this was played i thought the
game is over
now the next stage i think i played
really well in
um
okay so
because this is a complicated position
let's understand why 92 is so scary so
everybody should see the threat
the threat is knight takes g3 and this
is mate because the pawn is pinned
now the first instinct should be to move
the bishop but no matter where you move
it there are problems if we move it to
c7 which is the only feasible square on
this diagonal
i was worried about the simple rook ac8
what does this threaten
well this threatens rook takes c7 right
and then again knight g3 is made
there's not much that white can do here
what if you try in this position folks
to defend the g3 square
by playing queenie one
who can tell me the winning
who can tell me the winning sequence for
black
is rook takes c7 still good
no no we'll get to queen one immediately
in just a second that's what i played
yes it is still a good move why because
bishop d6 excellent tactical vision
and the the the pressure on h2 is
totally overwhelming
h3 bang
and just look at white's king this is
checkmate within a couple of moves
okay
so that's out of the question
what if you drop the bishop back to e1
well as we already know bishop d6 is
totally devastating because there is no
good way to defend against g3 against h2
um
okay
well that doesn't leave us with a lot of
options right if we can't move the
bishop anywhere
that's why i played queen e1 because the
only other thing we can do is to defend
the bishop and that's the only way to
defend the bishop
so
the reason i played this move with a
very heavy heart is because giving away
the dark squared bishop is terrifying
because it creates this very very weak
diagonal which black exploited what
about g3 there where
where after bishop b1 bishop d6 g3 yeah
but bishop takes g3 no
bishop takes g3
and and black again uses the spin
everything collapses now you could avoid
mate probably yeah you could avoid mate
but you're going to lose a bunch of your
other pieces
right
okay queen e1
i take c3 zolotoy
you can't just say on the basis of one
move i i appreciate your your the fact
that you're putting your faith in me and
you're saying that if somebody found a
move that i didn't find
then you know he's cheating i appreciate
that that means you think i'm
good but i i assure you that that's not
the case that's not how chess works
if you know
you should trust my experience in this i
would say if i was suspicious
so i i'd ask you respectfully to not to
stop
uh continuing to claim that you know
it's suspicious that he found one move
in one instance faster than i found it
my students find
solve stuff fast for me all the time it
happens if you take a thousand positions
then as you as you increase the amount
of positions
if he finds a faster move than me a
hundred times out of a hundred then it's
suspicious but once it's nothing
okay rook a d8
so this threatens bishop d6 so i played
the move h3
um
now bishop d6 no longer works
so he has to move the bishop back now we
played the move c3 i'm really proud of
myself for playing the move no no you're
good you're totally good
just trying to explain my perspective so
why did i play c3 here as it turned out
later this move was actually saved our
life this move saved our life and i'll
explain why a little bit later
and now bishop d6 forces the queen back
and bishop takes h3 is the kind of move
that if it works it's a double x-clam
move but if it doesn't it was not worth
sacrificing the bishop of course black
can kind of win this game by playing
something more mundane
but
i think the more mundane move was queen
to e5
threatening
checkmate on h2 how would we have
defended against this we would have
played the move g4 only move that's
actually why i played queen f2 here and
not queen f3
because queen f3 would have run into
queen e5 and now we have no defense
against mate we have to play g3 and give
a bunch of pawns so queen f2 bishop
takes h3 takes takes
king ji won
why not queen g1 asks
you mean here i was like what are you
guys talking about yeah queen g1 is also
possible queen g1 is also possible
uh but it's very passive i i don't
really like the placement of the queen
here i think g4 also prevents f5 so it
sort of kills two birds with one stone
anyways
so he sacrifices the bishop
he plays knight h4 it looks like it's
made again why is this such a dangerous
move if we play something random knight
f3 is a deflection sacrifice followed by
a checkmate on h2 so the only defense
here is for us to shift the queen to the
side so that the rook guards f3 division
of labor right division of labor is very
important in defending and this is why
c3 was so valuable because bishop c5
check would have been basically
checkmate if the pawn was on c2 it would
have been mate immediately here we can
play the move d4 did i see that when i
played c3 no
but let's remember why i played c3 in
the first place i played it in order to
prepare the move d4 so i played it in
order to prepare the same move in a
different context
so in a sense yes i anticipated it but
not exactly in this situation
okay so
does black evil win in this position let
me tell you what i was most worried
about
i was most worried about
the move rook
d
to e8
what is the purpose of this move the
purpose of this move
is exactly the same thing as what our
opponent played so our opponent repeated
moves once and then played bishop e5
except bishop e5 contains this hidden
drawback
in that it allows the knight to swing
around to eve at f5 and somehow prevent
the rook lift
yeah oh bishop c5 and rook d6 that might
also work
so some of you come up with this idea no
i don't think it does because i think
here you again have this check on e7 oh
my lions girl and now i think you can
take the bishop
no but here black is a win who can find
the win in this position
this is amazing
black has a really nice sequence here
it's amazing it's nice
oh there's a beautiful concept oh my god
i think i see a beautiful win here check
first
okay so rook h6 is winning but you guys
want me to knock your socks off can
anybody find an incredibly gorgeous move
that might win even faster
because rook h6 maybe white can play
queen h2 you can actually play knight f3
knight f3
look at this move
if cd then this is checkmate
if white takes the knight maybe i over
hyped this then rook h6 is made we can
check the engine but i'm pretty sure
this move leads to checkmate
knight h4 to f3
incredible
knight g2 would not work
because here i can take the rook and
this is no longer made
so only knight f3 to cover the g1 square
works
okay
so
the question that we are trying to
answer is whether rook d6 actually wins
the game
and i think we're starting to reach the
conclusion that it very well might
um
so we will check the the engine but i
was worried also about rook de-8
simply intending to lift the rook up
like this i don't even think black needs
to be fancy i don't think that we have
any way as white
to deal with to to to extricate
ourselves from this situation because
all of these pieces are firmly screwed
in place we have nothing with which to
kick the queen out of h3 does that make
sense if we play knight f4 great
question we lose our rook bishop takes
f4 rook takes f4 and now queen g3 check
and this forks the king and the rook
maybe this is most resilient but it
still loses question american let's get
those subs in thank you for the prime
would rook h2 work here valentinian in
which position
do you mean rook f2 and if so in which
position you mean here rook f2
uh rook f2 actually might be a resilient
defensive move
but i think that that doesn't actually
address the problem of the rook lift i
could play rook e6 or rookie 5
valentinian
and uh i think i don't think you can
stop me from getting to g6 if i'm
if i'm accurate
in my assessment here or or even rookie
5.
93 rook g5 knight g2 check checkmate
so that wins
now there was another proposal
which is to play knight e3 here
just to play knight e3 here that's
really interesting because that does
prevent rookie 6
but it does not prevent rookie 5 ob 068
with a prime
but maybe
oh what a line okay so here i want to go
rook g5 right
how can you try to prevent that how can
you try to prevent rook g5 bobby blake
with a prime
yeah
now we're talking
well queen h2 rook g5 does not help
because then we lose the queen on h2 you
could try knight f5 but this doesn't
work
because then black takes out a 5
and after rook takes f5 who sees the
move and when you're attacking you
always have to remember to check for
other tactics don't just limit yourself
to looking for mate here is a great
example of that queen takes f5 all of a
sudden whoop and black wins the rook he
takes f5 rook takes e2 and we lose the
game we we're down a row
so i don't think there is a defense to
rook to e8 we will check the engine
but in the game black plays the move
bishop b5 same idea but the wrong
execution because it allows us to
maneuver the knight to f5 and by the
skin of our teeth i think we're holding
this position together probably black
should have taken that knight
probably black should have taken that
knight
which way would we have taken back who
can tell me which way white should take
back here be very careful
remember that you are trying to prevent
the rook lift rook d6 to g6
so there is a move here that i think
everybody would want to play and that's
rook takes f5 i think it's wrong because
it doesn't actually stop the rook lift
now you might say wait a second isn't
the bishop hanging well it is but that's
beside the point because the rook lift
is still devastating even without the
bishop
here here here check me right
so none of that works
so we should play e takes f5
um and the reason
that's effective is because
the g6 square is now protected
the bishop on e5 is hanging black
probably needs to burn a tempo to defend
that bishop
and if he does then we can slide the
queen over to g2 we are still
undoubtedly worse here white's king is
still in bad shape but we're holding on
we've the worst is behind us you know
what i'm saying
so i think after knight f5 we're already
holding and after knight g6 we get a
rook to f3 then we get our queen to g2
and probably this end game is already
better for white i messed up this ending
as well
but that's sort of beside the point
after knight f4 check
okay so we went d4
here i started playing for tricks
probably what white should do in a
position like this
yeah so here i decided to play for
tricks and i couldn't resist the
temptation to play rook g4
what is the purpose of that move well if
black had allowed it
we would have taken on h5 with checkmate
the only defense is rook d7 the
brilliant move by the way by our
opponent
type 2 prophylaxis right you don't
prevent the actual move you take the
sting out of it and the point is the
rook swing stage 7. i don't see any
other defensive moves if black plays h4
you might say okay let me just put the
pawn on a defended square that doesn't
work either because we can simply take
on h4 and then take again we have two
rooks there again this is checkmate
so if i was playing objectively
then i probably would have played a
different move maybe rook back to g1
maybe just a4 expand on the queen side
something like that
and by the way if we take on h5 first
this almost works literally the only
move again is rook d7 this darn
defensive resource and the rook swings
to h7 without this move black is
checkmated even king h7 does not help
this is still mate
look at this mating construction
i mean it's crazy
why aren't we worried about losing the
rook on g3 there so i explained this
during the game
a lot of you guys who are you know let's
say 1300 and below
your focus should very much be on
tactical drawbacks of the move that you
make so when you play rook g3 i would be
scared if you didn't see that you're
walking into a potential discovery but
the higher rated you get the more
concrete your thinking has to become so
when i look at this i see that the rook
walks into a potential discovery but
then i ask myself is it at all realistic
that there emerges a scary discovery and
the answer to that question is no here's
the reason why
a move like 92 is not going to be scary
not because the rook can move but
because we can simply take the knight
and then we can take the bishop and
we'll have two pieces for a rook and if
the knight makes a retreating move then
it only creates one threat and the rook
will be able to move
so
this this construction looks scary but
if you break it down you realize that
there's actually nothing
scary to it at all
knight d3 check is bad for a variety of
reasons rook takes d3 or even bishop
takes d3 there are no useful discoveries
so we go rook h1
we got g4 and unfortunately our our
opponent playing so well this end game
rook h7
maybe h4 was a mistake because it does
allow us to stick our bishop on g4
although i did blunder another fork and
i did blunder the pawn
so
in this position
i think our opponent would have been
best advised to drop the knight back to
d6 come on guys let the hype train go
you can do better than that
boo
knight d6 i think would have been a
better idea trying to get rid of our
strongest piece
knight a5 was a mistake i think it
allowed us to get a rook to a good
square and here our opponent
unfortunately disconnected lost on time
and black is better here i mean black is
up a pawn
probably should get the knight back
around to c6 and
you know we we do have a very nice
center here and it might be hard for
black to make any progress but
a sad end to the game unsatisfying but i
think this was absolutely fascinating
overall now it's time for us to check a
couple of things with the engine well
the accuracy is going to be low probably
for me because i blunted a piece
okay solid solid accuracy for both of us
i think
obviously this this contributed a lot
okay so
it's interesting this is the first
moment we wanted to check
bishop e5 is
okay it's not perfect apparently the
best the best
line i want the analysis though there we
go
yeah so oh knight a4 existed
aha so we should have played knight a4
here to target the bishop
and if bishop d6
then we trade
at least we got rid of black's dark
squared bishop and now we can expand in
the center with c3 and now we can expand
in the center with c3 knight e6
and d4 aha
and now we have a nice center so the
best move here was actually to move
knight to a4 to take this bishop out of
commission
okay bishop b5 isn't great when h5 is
good
knight g6 was inaccurate according to
the engine okay whatever knight t5 of
course blundering 92
queen e1 ooh bishop c7 actually was the
best move
rookie c8
oh my god and now we have
the crazy engine move d4
holy smokes knight takes d4
and then b4
oh my god
wow ridiculous
yeah i mean it's still lost knight back
to e6 but the point is it makes sense
actually why d4 because we're trying to
get rid of this bishop we are also
opening up an attack on the knight on e2
so if bishop takes d4 then we play
bishop takes c2
and all of a sudden this bishop hangs so
black has to take with a knight now we
play b4
exploiting the weakness of this
construction
knight e6
bc knight c7 black is still up a piece
but it gets a little bit messy here so
hopefully i can be forgiven for missing
this
okay here here here this is good h3
bishop p6
ah so this is actually good and let's
see whether we were able to figure out
the truth of this position
oh bishop p5 is good
but the best move is rook de-8 i was
right the best move is rook de-8 and
this wins on the spot the best line
according to the engine actually is this
which we analyzed
now bishop c5 check
d4 and rook d6
is wrong
and it's because of king f2 we can
actually run
we can actually run away with our own
two feet we can run away to e1 and the
engine gives us as equal
yeah king f2 is an incredible defensive
move like right into the teeth of the
attack
so bishop c5 does not win
our opponent played bishop e5 97 check
knight f5 we found the only defensive
resource
oh my god
and this is the mistake
oh my god b5
what
what is b5
okay i have so many questions here first
of all
oh bishop b3
oh my god i see this is brilliant so
bishop b3 the point the point and allow
me to explain the point is that here
black can take the pawn on d3 right this
should make sense because the rook is
coming to g3
i know it's crazy
but what if bishop takes b5 you might
ask now the point is that the rook
shifts over to b8
start with top down thinking what is
black's biggest and most important goal
it's to get the rook onto the sixth rank
at all costs it doesn't matter which
airport you fly into b6 c6 e6 as long as
the rook reaches the sixth rank the game
is over that's actually why we put the
knight on f5 to prevent rook d6 so the
point of the move b5 is that either you
allow the entry point through the third
rank or you allow the entry point
through b6 because the bishop is hanging
and if white saves the bishop then rook
b6 ends the game because the rook lift
is unstoppable if you play d4
still rook b6 de5 rook g6 check king f2
and this is
not immediately over you can even play
knight takes f5 here
threatening this checkmate and the
attack is overwhelming it's plus five
and if white plays bishop to d5
then
you play knight takes f5 rook takes f5
and again rook d6 and if he takes f5
then that bishop is going to hang
b7 b5 i mean is that brilliant or what
but does the point of this move make
sense it's not the only winning move
it's not the only move apparently
the slow bishop c7 is also winning
not sure why although this is not that
clear minus 1.7 it's already a game
so the only clearly winning move is b7
b5
absolutely unbelievable
this is what i would call brilliant you
know chess.com can definitely work on
their assignment of brilliant moves b5 i
would say is like triple x clamp
whereas bishop takes h3 is nice but i
wouldn't call it brilliant it's totally
inhuman
i would give this to like a 2400 student
like i would give this move to
astronomy for it shouldn't give him 15
minutes to think about it
this was absolutely incredible
um
knight g6 is clearly a sign that
you know black has let it go
and at this point the engine
oh
we're winning
ah so this is a mistake we should have
gone e5 and drove this wedge into
black's position
instead i went here
yeah so rook g4 was was playing for
traps oh we had bishop e2
oh that's such a nice move attacking the
pawn and if h4
knight takes h4 and we have the ladder
mate if black takes it
oh
and if knight takes e2 we return to f5
and then we calmly play rook gh3 with a
devastating attack against the king
now this is totally flannable you know
why i didn't find it i was so
emotionally attached to the bishop being
here
and you know why i was emotionally
attached to it this is a classic example
of psychology interfering with finding
the best move i was already fixated on
the mating idea of taking on h5 what is
integral to that mating idea it's the
fact that the bishop is guarding the g8
square
right that's why this mate works so you
have to
disattach yourself
from
like there's a phrase in in i think
writing kill your darlings which
basically means i think that the the
sentences that you like the most
when you're writing stories are the ones
that often have to be killed off and
deleted because you're not able to
approach them objectively it's the same
with ideas when you get really fixated
on an idea
it you often aren't able to find other
ideas that kind of interfere with it so
this is a very instructive moment bishop
e2 would have been super strong
instead we play this terrible move
and then our opponent
oh king f3 was best but okay at this
point we're both in time pressure
yeah and uh
this is where he disconnected so i think
overall this was a great game
so much to analyze so many instructive
moments i'm glad we did this
i'm really really glad we did this
[Music]